Jack Babbitt:I was in Purdue University in
my first year there and I wanted to serve,
so I joined the Army Air Corps. Overseas as
a pilot in B17's, flew 29 combat missions
and a couple of missions dropping food to
the Dutch. Flew home on my birthday and the
war was over. That was my military career.
You've always heard there were no atheists
in a foxhole, believe me there were no atheists
in an airplane either.
Jo Babbitt: Both my brothers, older brothers
were in the war. One was taken prisoner and
was in a German concentration camp. I remember
the impact that that had on our family and
the importance of prayer at that time.
Jack Babbitt: One of the visits that started
all of this was we were there on Sunday, that's
what led Jo to say, "Well, where are these
students worshiping? Where are they going
to church? There's a big need here."
Jo Babbitt: It was interesting to me to think
that as you look at the campus you didn't
see the prominence of a place to worship where
they could go and just have a quiet meditation
time with the Lord. So I ask Mr. Cervini,
"Why not a chapel?" He said, "Well, interesting
you should mention that, that's something
for the future." To me, the future is now.
Larry P. Arnn: Hillsdale has had a chapel
for most of its history. In the 1850's it
built College Baptist Church down the street.
Well, we use the College Baptist Church today
but the college is more than twice as big
as it was back then, we cannot all get into
it anymore. College in America and medieval
times in Europe have always had academic religious
ceremonies. We call the main ones here are
convocation. You need the whole campus community
to get together and we don't have a place
to do that that's proper for it. Why do it
now? Well, there are a lot of reasons, but
one of them is Mr. Babbitt and his wife Jo
are keen for us to build it. We're very grateful
for that and they've given us a significant
gift to get started on it. If we can get the
rest of the money, now is a better time than
tomorrow.
The two chief ways of knowing are reason and
faith and they are different ways of knowing.
There is some significant overlap between
them. There's never been a great university
that was not heavily concerned with the question
of God. There's never been serious Christian
practice that was not heavily concerned with
learning. To take one of them out is to deprive
it of an essential element. This chapel will
be a daily reminder of that essential fact.
Always remembered here, never remembered too
much.
Duncan Stroik: Inspiration for the new Christ
chapel started with looking at Central Hall.
The yellow brick on the front porch, the two
towers or pavilions to either side, the large
arched window in the middle is actually inspired
by the round window at Central Hall which
is the spot where there was a chapel at one
time, so it's where we started. What was the
inspiration for the inside? The interior of
the chapel is inspired by that quintessential
English church St. Martin-in-the-Fields which
is the model for most early American churches.
Where you have a major nave, large columns
supporting a big vault and balconies, because
the college wanted to have a church that seats
1,300 that would feel intimate for 600. The
balconies lead your eye towards the pulpit,
towards the table, the altar, and there we
have an organ and a beautiful serliana window.
So the interior is inspired by St. Martin-in-the-Fields,
and St. Martin-in-the-Fields is the model
for such great churches as Christ Church in
Philadelphia where the Founding Fathers met
during the Continental Congress.
Megan Bowser: The liberal arts are concerned
with that which is true. So when you're studying
the liberal arts, and understanding the world
around you and what it means to be human,
you come to the conclusion that to be human
is to be made in the image of God.
Leah Hickman: I see this chapel as being a
visible reminder of God's presence on the
campus and his plan for what he wants the
students and faculty to do for his kingdom.
Drew French: I believe that building a chapel
on this campus will be the perfect symbol
of what has been happening at Hillsdale for
years. That is the serious pursuit of truth,
particularly in scripture and generally in
all of the liberal arts.
Larry P. Arnn: The college has four purposes
and they are: freedom, high learning that's
learning the ultimate goods in nature and
God, the development of high moral character,
and the propagation of the Christian faith.
Those four things are central at Hillsdale
College, they have not been changed since
1844. So of course the chapel that has to
be right in the middle of everything.
Jo Babbitt: We just feel that the placement
of it is the absolute perfect place because
it just makes you aware of God's presence
on campus. You know, you go by and you cannot
help but think, "That's my faith, that's the
foundation that all of this learning is building
to."
Larry P. Arnn: The first thing we're going
to do and it is we're going to have convocation
and baccalaureate. Convocation, there are
four of them a year, including commencement.
We all gather, we wear our robes, the choir
sings, we say prayers. So there will also
be 30 prayer group meetings a day at Hillsdale
College. There are 3 or 4 religious services
every day and those will be held in the chapel
and in the side chapel, a home for those.
Then the chapel's going to be a great place
for music. More than 30% of our students are
involved in music. We have an 85 piece orchestra,
we have 150 people in a chorus. They sing
and play a lot of sacred music, the chorus
mostly sacred music. We are going to put in
the chapel 2 world-class organs, and we want
to have choral evensong and the major orchestral
and choral performances will be in the chapel.
I came here 16 years ago. The specific reason
that I decided that I would work here if they
would have me, and they had said that they
would, is that I read those beautiful original
articles of the college. Those articles were
written by New England preachers who'd come
to the frontier. Some of them became friends
of Abraham Lincoln and they did wonderful
things in the cause of Lincoln. So as in the
founding, the practice of the Christian faith
gave powerful support to the greatest movement
of freedom in all of human history. I came
here with a love for that and a wish to make
that stronger and better. The chapel is actually
the last significant structure that requires
to be built to complete that work. The work
will never be complete, but the structures
will all be in place. Won't that be something?
I pray for that.
Jack Babbitt: We didn't enter into this whole
thing with Hillsdale very lightly. The Lord
has blessed us, more than we ever thought
would b. With a blessing we also had the responsibility
to him to be good stewards because it's all
his money, so where does this money go? We
prayed many times that this would be the proper
place. We believe it is the proper place because
it will have students in there that are going
to change the world, and we need them, we
need them badly.